thank you all so much for joining this
installment of the Yale program for the
study of anti-semitisms
um
Benjamin and Barbara Zucker lecture
series I'm Josh Cowan I'm an assistant
professor of political science and
statistics and data science at Yale
University and I'm very excited to be
inviting Laura Royden to
give us a talk today on anti-semitic
attitude among Young Americans
Laura is a fifth year PhD student in the
government department at Harvard
University she is currently focused on
anti-Semitism and Jewish politics but
also interested in election in judicial
politics prior to starting her PhD at
Harvard Laura worked at the Brennan
Center for justice in the Harvard
Kennedy School she completed her
undergraduate studies at MIT in urban
studies and planning in 2014 and we're
very excited to have you at this joint
program of the Yale program for the
study of anti-Semitism and the American
and comparative political Behavior
Workshop throughout the talk if you have
any questions please put those in the Q
a and if they're clarifying questions
during the talk I will moderate those
and and potentially interrupt Laura with
those clarifying questions and then if
you have substantive questions please
try and save those for the end and put
those in the Q a and zoom chat is
disabled and we're not going to call on
people so please just put everything in
that q a function and with that I will
hand it over to Laura thank you Laura
thanks Josh for that introduction thanks
to Yale for having me and thanks to
everyone for coming today I'm really
excited to be here to talk about this
project which has been a joint effort
with Aton Hirsch at Tufts broadly
speaking this project is a series of
survey questions and experiments that we
designed to examine anti-semitic
attitudes among American adults I think
we originally envisioned this project
being one paper but it ended up turning
into three because we realized we really
wanted enough space to be able to
discuss the topic and our results with
the level of nuance that I think we can
all agree it deserves
three papers is obviously way too much
to present fully in the next 45 minutes
so I'm going to present some of the core
findings from one of the papers
which was recently published in prq for
the political scientists
and this one focuses on ideological and
age dimensions of anti-Semitic attitudes
in the U.S so I'm going to talk through
our Theory our hypotheses and our
findings and then briefly by
highlighting our work in the other two
papers of course I'm happy to talk about
those papers or more detailed findings
from this one later or offline with
anyone
so why did we decide to do this project
well starting about five years ago we've
seen a series of high-profile
anti-semitic incidents in America we've
seen the Tree of Life shooting the
Charlottesville unite the right March
but also more common incidents like the
defacement of synagogues and harassment
of Jewish Americans both violently and
non
and all of this has perhaps
unsurprisingly been paralleled by a
sharp increase in perceived concern
about anti-semitism
as of last year 62 percent of all
Americans and 88 of Jewish Americans now
consider anti-Semitism a problem
one in four Jews surveyed by the AJC or
the American Jewish committee said that
they had personally experienced
anti-Semitism in the past year
so there's certainly a recent salience
to anti-Semitism in American politics
and a sense that it's something worth
looking at empirically
but we also noticed something else that
made this a compelling topic
which is that there's a lot of focus in
news media and popular commentators not
just on this rise of anti-Semitism but
specifically on how anti-Semitism seems
to be popping up on both the far left
and the far right and I really mean
there's a lot of focus really quite a
lot of focus about the relationship
between extreme ideology and
anti-semitism
now this makes sense because many of the
recent high-profile anti-semitic
incidents like the ones I just mentioned
have been associated with either far
left or far-right politics not just one
or the other
but a Prejudice Rising on both
ideological extremes yet not in the
center is a fairly unique and
interesting pattern that we don't see
very much in American politics so
naturally being the political scientists
that we are we decided to focus this
project on getting a clearer picture of
the pattern and whether it exists in
Mass public attitudes instead of just as
these anecdotes
now we're calling this pattern the
Horseshoe pattern of anti-Semitism
because it mirrors a broader theory of
ideology known as horseshoe Theory
and Horseshoe theory is the idea that
ideology is in a straight line running
from far left to far right as we would
usually think about it but instead it's
bent like a horseshoe so functionally
what this means is we would have the
center at the top of the Horseshoe and
bent down so that the far left and the
far right are actually much closer to
each other than they are to the center
now horseshoe Theory became somewhat
well known in American politics around
the 2016 election with the simultaneous
rise of the Bernie left and the Trump
right which arguably both share a
populist base and frustration with the
prior ruling Elites in both parties
it hasn't really gained traction as a
broad Theory to explain American
politics but it has endured in
discussions of American anti-semitism
two recent popular books one by Barry
Weiss he used to work for the New York
Times and one by Deborah lipstadt a
well-known historian who's now actually
leading the Biden administration's work
on anti-Semitism do a great job of fully
laying out the case for why this
horseshoe pattern might have arisen
and why might that be
well extreme anti-Semitism on both sides
could have a shared cause
if burgeoning populism among these
extremes leads to a frustration with the
capitalist status quo this could feed
into Old stereotypes about Jews as
shadowy overlords who control government
and finance which could then lead to an
increase in anti-semitic attitudes on
both ideological extremes
but it could also be for independent
reasons that happen to both be occurring
now
growing white nationalists growing white
nationalist sentiment on the far right
might lead directly to anti-semitic
attitudes with Jews being seen as a
shady group either pretending to be
white or siding with the non-white
population politically given how liberal
American Jews are
anti-semitic sentiment on the far left
on the other hand may have spilled over
from their views on Israel as the
political left has steadily become more
supportive of the Palestinian cause and
more critical towards Israel
we've seen Progressive politicians draw
direct comparisons between black lives
matter because that obviously holds a
lot of leftist support with the
Palestinian cause
so if the far-right has begun to view
Israel negatively and as the clear
oppressor in the Palestinian conflict
those negative views May spill over
towards Jews more broadly
so we designed this project primarily to
examine whether or not this horseshoe
pattern of anti-Semitism exists for
either of the above reasons but there's
one important Wrinkle In The Horseshoe
pattern of anti-Semitism that we really
wanted to focus on as well
and that's what's going on with young
adults in terms of anti-semitism
so there's two reasons why looking at
young adults anti-semitic attitudes here
is interesting the first is that we know
from prior work that young adults are
generally more tolerant less prejudicial
hold more Cosmopolitan attitudes than
older adults do but a number of Prior
Studies have found that they actually
tend to have higher rates specifically
of anti-semitism
it's been theorized that this may be to
the declining salience of the Holocaust
as we move further away from World War
II or to the increased salience of the
israel-palestine conflict particularly
given the more liberal leanings of young
adults so we're interested to see if
this is still true but we're also
interested to see whether there was an
ideological Dimension specific to young
adult anti-semitism
and that's because there are two
ideological movements that may make the
Horseshoe pattern more extreme
specifically among young adults
on the right
we've seen the growth of the white
nationalist alt-right which has occurred
primarily online and thus has gained a
large following specifically among young
men
on the left we've seen a huge burst in
pro-palestinian activism on college
campuses and in social justice circles
which are heavily populated by young
adults now both of these movements May
really increase the pathways to extreme
anti-Semitism I described on the
previous slide and thus could accentuate
the Horseshoe pattern so we focused on
young adults to see if that was indeed
the case
so we wanted to examine Mass attitudes
among young adults and the ideological
extremes so what did we do
of course we ran an original survey it
was fielded by yougov right after the
2020 election and we have this big 2500
person oversample of younger adults in
order to really be able to examine the
rise in anti-Semitism that might be most
prominent among this age group and we
also have a thousand person sample of
the full adult population so that gives
us a 3 500 person sample in total which
we can and will break into smaller
groups
before I get into the meat of the survey
here's the distribution of the
respondents ideologically most of our
analysis is using a standard seven point
ideology scale going from very liberal
to very conservative
but we did also duplicate the analysis
using an alternative measure of ideology
so we explicitly asked respondents if
they identify as more extreme labels
like alt right or leftists and rerunning
all of the analysis with those labels we
get essentially the same results
so for Simplicity and ease of
understanding I'm going to present
everything here using the seven point
ideology scale but just know that this
does hold up even if we just look at
more extreme identifiers so you can see
the distribution here we do have more
liberal young adults than we do older
adults and we also have more liberal
young adults than we do
conservative young adults but thirty
percent of our young sample is still
conservative so that's fairly good we
have a fairly good distribution here and
enough to really be able to analyze
these buckets our sample of older adults
is fairly well distributed
as well
so before I show you the questions we
use to measure anti-Semitism I want to
pause and note that there have been
Decades of debate about how exactly to
Define anti-Semitism or what counts as
anti-Semitism and it certainly Still
Remains a Hot Topic
so here we're primarily focusing on
attitudes that respondents hold towards
American Jews do they think of Jews in
stereotypical or demonizing ways or do
they treat Jews differently from how
they treat other minority groups
and we decided to measure this form of
anti-Semitism in two different ways
we measure overt anti-Semitism via
direct agreement with specific claims
about Jews and then we also measure more
subtle anti-Semitism through a series of
experiments about whether Jews are held
to higher standards than other groups of
Americans now we do this for two reasons
the first is to feel more confident in
our results by triangulating Across the
strengths and weaknesses of these two
ways to measure prejudice
the second reason is to respond to
another key aspect of the popular
discussion around ideological
anti-semitism
which is this repeated idea that
left-wing anti-Semitism is more subtle
or that it's more Insidious and gets
glossed over
that it goes under the radar
and that this has really allowed the
left to essentially hide its
anti-Semitism and avoid addressing it as
sort of real anti-semitism
so in order to try and measure what
these commentators argue are somewhat
hidden views we also really wanted to
include these less overt survey
experiments to potentially draw out
these hidden yet honest views if they
exist
so I'm going to start with our overt
anti-Semitism battery
which consists of three questions with
different anti-semitic stereotypes Jews
are more loyal to Israel than to America
it's appropriate to boycott Jewish
businesses as a form of opposition to
Israel and that Jews in the United
States have too much power
now these are questions that have been
asked before by organizations and
researchers to measure anti-Semitism but
as an additional check we also took any
respondent who said they were Jewish and
instead of asking them if they agreed
with these statements although the
results there might be a little bit
interesting we instead ask them if they
found them anti-semitic and across the
board at least 75 percent of Jewish
respondents agreed that each statement
was anti-semitic we see agreement as
high as 90 for the boycott measure so
that's another indication that these are
probably reasonable questions to gauge
anti-semitism
and now we paired this over
anti-Semitism battery with a priming
experiment
half of our respondents were first
primed with the following quote which is
a true finding explaining that Gallup
found that 95 of Jews have favorable
views of Israel
and we did this to see if we could draw
out any of this potentially masked
anti-Semitism since Perhaps Perhaps
priming respondents who are already
critical of Israel with information that
Jews are an out group to them on this
issue would make them respond more
negatively and perhaps more honestly
about their views of Jews respondents
may feel more okay responding with their
true beliefs if it could be viewed as a
criticism of Israel instead of just
anti-Semitism in other words
so we had a few different hypotheses
first we expected to find that
anti-semitic attitudes would be higher
among the ideological Extremes in other
words giving us this horseshoe shaped
pattern
we expected to find that younger adults
would in general be more anti-semitic
than older adults but we also expected
that the Horseshoe pattern would be more
extreme among younger adults in other
words we expected that most of the
increase in anti-Semitism among younger
adults would be among the far left and
the far right young adults rather than
sort of uniformly increased across all
young adults
and finally we expected that the prime
about Israel should increase
anti-semitic attitudes specifically on
the ideological left since that's where
we expect
anti-semitic attitudes if they exist to
be intertwined with anti-israel
attitudes
so
what did we find
here we have charts showing agreement
with each of the three overt
anti-Semitism questions the x-axis on
each each chart is going from very
liberal to very conservative and we have
the percentage of respondents in each
bucket who agreed with the statement on
the y-axis
the black dots here show agreement among
younger adults again those are people
aged 18 to 30. and the gray squares show
agreement among older adults or those
over 30.
so right off the bat we can see that
there's no evidence of horseshoe Theory
here for all three questions among
younger and older adults respondents on
the far left have some of the lowest
rates of agreement with the overt
anti-semitic statements
so instead of a horseshoe pattern which
we would expect to look something like
this
we see that agreement with anti-semitic
statements broadly increases as we move
from Liberal to conservative
but we can also see that there's a more
complicated relationship with age here
that seems to be modified by ideology
there isn't much difference on the left
between younger and older adults
here here and here
but there's a strong difference on the
right and we particularly see this in
the boycott and the too much power
measure and particularly among the most
conservative adults for these huge
40-point gaps here
so overall this means that younger
adults do have slightly higher agreement
especially with the boycott and power
measures but that's solely driven by
this really large increase over here
among the young far right and it's not
at all driven
by any increases among the young far
left
so in all
we don't see a horseshoe pattern and
instead we see much higher agreement on
the far right particularly on Far Right
so moving on to looking at the prime
which as a reminder told respondents
first that 95 of American Jews have a
positive view of Israel
so this chart shows our full sample with
all adults just for Simplicity because
the results here don't vary by age
here again we have ideology on the
x-axis moving from very liberal to very
conservative an agreement with each
statement on the y-axis
so this time the black dots represent
agreement levels for respondents who saw
the prime
well whereas the gray squares represent
agreement levels for respondents who did
not
and we expected that the prime would
increase anti-semitic sentiments on the
left
which probably has more anti-israel
sentiments as well however we don't
really see that that's the case
we get null and or small effects almost
across the board here we really do not
see much impact for the prime
the only place we really do see
substantial effects is right here
among moderates when it comes to
agreeing specifically that Jews are more
loyal to Israel than they are to America
you see about a 20 point increase here
for moderates
now the prime not working doesn't
necessarily mean that the left doesn't
hold negative views of Israel
it could be instead that it's common
knowledge that Jews hold favorable views
towards Israel for a lot of our
respondents and thus they didn't gain
any new information from the prime
and perhaps then the prime worked on
moderates specifically for the Loyalty
measure because some research has found
that moderates may in general know less
about politics and or be less set in
their beliefs so they might be more
moved by the prime specifically for the
relevant statement about Israel loyalty
another option could be that the prime
just wasn't strong enough to counteract
social desirability bias on the left so
even when prompted with information
about Israel they still know that they
shouldn't Express these sentiments about
Jews now this lingering concern about
social desirability bias on the left
brings us nicely to
our double standard experiments which we
use to see if respondents across the
Spectrum are treating Jews differently
from how they treat other groups
so these experiments reduce social
desirability concerns a bit since we're
going to be asking the same question but
with different minority groups
substituted in so if they have concerns
about expressing these sentiments they
should
feel it a little less if it's directly
compared to another group
so how do we do this well
again here we split our respondents into
two groups we asked one group if they
thought Jewish Americans who participate
in social justice activism should have
to denounce Israel's discrimination
against non-jews and we asked the second
group if they thought the same thing but
for Muslim Americans
denouncing Muslim countries
discrimination of non-muslims
now we picked this question because
there have been anecdotal news stories
about organizations particularly on
college campuses or in other social
justice spaces that have pressured
Jewish members to denounce Israel or
denounce Zionism if they want to
participate and we really wanted a real
world example here that respondents
might have thought about or heard about
sorry Laura just to jump in with a
clarifying question can you explain a
little bit more how this double standard
experiment helps reduce social
desirability bias so folks you're doing
this between subjects design so folks
are still being asked either just about
Jews or just about Muslims yeah why if
they're being asked out Jews don't you
think there's a chance they might hide
their true opinion so there definitely
is still a chance but there's also a
chance they would hide it against
Muslims as well so I guess it's not it's
sort of evening the playing field a
little bit about social desirability
bias because we can ask essentially the
same question about two different groups
so we might think that social
desirability bias is going to come into
play for both Jews and Muslims
got into the assumption is there's like
this standard Baseline level of social
desirability bias against both groups
we're going to partial that out by
looking at the difference between the
Jews and Muslims exactly yeah yeah it
seems plausible do you have any yeah
it'd be interesting data to check that
but I'll let you keep going thanks yeah
so this chart here now shows results
with the percentage of respondents both
from the full sample and just young
adults who agreed with either statement
the black squares here show the
respondents who said that Jews should
denounce Israel whereas the gray circles
show respondents who said that Muslims
should denounce Muslim countries
we expected to see an anti-jewish double
standard on the left and an anti-muslim
double standard on the right
so let's just look at the first half of
this chart for here for now the all
adults chart
we see this is the case
but we see it to different magnitudes we
see this double standard on the left we
see this anti-jewish double standard on
the left with the far left being about
15 to 20 percentage points more likely
to say that Jews should denounce Israel
but looking at the far right
we see that the far right is about 40
percentage points more likely to say
that Muslims should denounce Muslim
discrimination
and now looking across the ideological
Spectrum just in this chart we do see
that those on the far left are more
likely overall to say that Jews should
have to denounce Israel than those on
the right for those on the left again
it's around a little less than 50
percent and on the right it's down here
around 20 25 percent
so this suggests that there may be some
forms of anti-Semitism such as the one
here about holding Jews to a certain
Collective standard
that may be more prominent on the left
than on the right
but if we look at just young adults in
the right panel we intriguingly see
something different
so here looking at respondents
agreements that Jews should denounce
Israel we see that both the young far
left and the young far right are much
more likely to agree with this
announcement than the center
so unlike any of our previous findings
here we do actually see this u-shaped
pattern
indicating that there is both a higher
standard for Jews on the left and the
right and this is our only indication so
far of any pattern that would match
horseshoe Theory
we also see that the results from
Muslims remain relatively similar as for
older adults generally
increases with ideology for both cases
and this suggests that something unique
might be going on here with young adults
and anti-semitism
but again there's actually relatively
little change between adults on the far
between all adults on the far left and
young adults on the far left the new
u-shaped pattern is coming from Far
Right young far right respondents being
about 15 percentage points more likely
to say that Jews should denounce Israel
than the older far-right respondents
were
so while there is some hint then that
the far left is exhibiting a double
standard towards Jews that doesn't seem
to vary by age the young far right
instead seems to have become much more
critical of Jews than older far-right
adults which both lines up with and
provides some Nuance to our prior
findings of anti-Semitism being the
strongest among the young far right
so we did a second double standard
experiment as well
to make sure that our answers weren't
solely being driven by views on Muslim
Americans
so here we use Catholic Americans and
Indian Americans as a comparison group
Catholics another religious group that
have an explicitly religious country
affiliated with them in the Vatican and
they've also been accused of holding
dual loyalty to the Vatican we use
Indian Americans here as another group
associated with a foreign Ally India and
Indian Americans also hold relatively
High socioeconomic status in the U.S for
a minority group
so this double standard experiment
actually had a few questions but I'm
just going to show one and again the
results are similar across the different
questions
so we again randomized our sample into
three groups and we asked each one if
they thought either Jewish Indian or
Catholic Americans should be held
responsible for Israel India or the
vatican's actions
and here we hypothesized that both the
political left and the political right
would be more willing to hold Jewish
Americans responsible for Israel's
actions
this might be the case due to
stereotypes of Jews as being more
powerful than other minority groups but
we thought this also might be present on
the far left due to discourse again
around Palestinian activism the role
Jewish Americans should play and general
criticism of Israel
but look real quick Laura yes we did a
clarifying question from Michelle can
you talk a little bit about the the
x-axis of the liberal mod conservative
so in particular Michelle wanted to know
did these subjects identify themselves
as far right or far left yeah so here
again these axes are going from we asked
people do you identify as
very Liberal Liberal somewhat liberal
moderate
somewhat conservative conservative and
very conservative so we have very
liberal here and very conservative here
again we did rerun all of this analysis
with specifically more extreme labels
um using the using like leftists
socialist Progressive alt-right
Christian conservative things like that
um and the results are essentially the
same but I'm using ideology here because
it's easier to see a nice Trend across
ideology from a more continuous measure
and we also have a question from Cheryl
on this measure of just like isn't held
accountable very different from you
should condemn so you could talk about
maybe some of the different measures you
looked at yeah definitely so held
accountable is much it's yeah it's we
wanted to use these different measures
here because we didn't want to just have
one specific measure so our held
accountable measure is slightly
different from our should condemn
measure we have another measure which is
whether or not these groups should do
more to make
whether Jewish Indian and Catholic
Americans should do more to make Israel
India and the Vatican sort of better
countries or like more yeah better
actors
essentially and yeah you're right that
these are potentially picking up on
different things so we wanted to change
them a little bit just to make sure
again that the specific wording in any
of our measures wasn't accidentally
picking up on a trend and giving us
spurious results
so
looking at our results here
we can see once again that we don't have
this horseshoe pattern among all adults
on the left
and among younger adults on the right
there's no horseshoe pattern we don't
see any of this u-shaped in both cases
adults on the far left are the least
oops are the least likely to hold Jews
accountable and there doesn't even seem
to really be an anti-jewish double
standard here
there's we actually find an
anti-catholic double standard which is
interesting but not the focus of this
talk
the far right also doesn't have an
anti-jewish double standard in both
cases they're the least likely to say
that Jews should be held accountable but
they're still more likely overall to say
the Jews should be held accountable for
Israel than people on the far left
and comparing all adults to younger
adults we again see that this age effect
scales as we move ideologically from
Liberal to conservative so there's
essentially no change
between younger between younger and
older adults on the left but on the far
right we see that younger far-right
adults are about 20 percentage points
more likely to hold Jews responsible for
Israel which again suggests that
something unique is going on here with
young far-right adults views on Jews
so tying this all together what did we
learn here about the ideological and age
patterns of anti-Semitism well we first
learned that there isn't much evidence
for a broad horseshoe pattern of
anti-Semitism even when we do see a
U-shaped graph anti-Semitism generally
remains much higher on the right
and so
we find that anti-semitic attitudes
generally are much higher on the far
right than they are on the far left
looking by age we do see that young
adults Express more anti-semitic
attitudes than older ones do but this is
almost entirely driven by a large
increase on the young right
now we do find a few anti-jewish double
standards on the left including a few
more subtle ones in the paper that I
didn't include here because they're
along the same lines as the Jewish
Muslim double standard but in each case
they're overshadowed by much stronger
anti-jewish views especially on the
young right for the same questions
so I'd say the one sentence takeaway
from this talk and this paper is that
horseshoe Theory does not seem to
accurately describe anti-Semitism in
America since we find that the epis f is
Center
is fairly clearly among the young far
right
but before I end I do want to quickly
talk about our other two papers which
shed light on interesting aspects
outside of horseshoe Theory here
so our second paper in this project
looks at anti-semitic attitudes among
racial minorities specifically Black and
Hispanic Americans so prior work has
long shown that these groups do tend to
hold more anti-semitic attitudes than
white Americans and we find that this is
true as well particularly among young
adults
somewhat concerningly we find that Black
and Hispanic respondents agree with
these overt anti-semitic statements at
around the same rate as white alt-right
respondents do
so with this finding we then examine
whether or not our results match any
previously proposed theories for
minority anti-Semitism these range from
greater Palestinian solidarity to
minority groups perhaps conflating Jews
with white people and actually
expressing anti-whiteness to Geographic
conflict or general group competition
among many others
so using other questions from our
surveys to test these theories we find
that actually none of these common
theories explain the differences that we
find among our respondents and this
suggests that we really need a new wave
of theorizing and a lot more research
into the intersection between race and
anti-Semitism to better figure out
what's going on here
our third paper is a little different
and it looks at the Young left young
left's views on Israel
so underlying a lot of the commentary on
left-wing anti-Semitism is the idea that
the far left particularly the young far
left really dislikes Israel
but the extent to which that's actually
empirically true was unclear so we
decided to find out
so using a few more experiments and
asking about specific countries
we find that the young left does seem to
have this persistently negative view
towards Israel they view Israel more
negatively than older liberals do or
other young adults do
and young far-left adults also view
Israel more negatively than they view
other countries allied with the United
States
so checking two plausible explanations
we find that this view doesn't seem to
be explained by an issue prioritization
of the israel-palestine conflict among
the left and we also find that their
negative attitudes extend beyond
criticisms of Israel's government and
seem to spill over into criticism of
things like Israel's culture languages
and religion
so these findings also don't fit neatly
with existing theories or what we'd
expect from partisan polarized views of
foreign countries so we again argue that
more research is really needed here to
Grapple seriously with what's going on
with views of both Jews and Israel
and that's all I have here I wanted to
mention that I have a few new projects
I'm starting on that are somewhat
related one is on the connection between
anti-Semitism and conspiracy theories
and another is on how the conditional
whiteness of Jews and Jews relatively
High status affects perceptions of
anti-Semitism but I'd love to hear from
everyone here any thoughts on what
people found the most compelling about
this or best directions to go in from
here with this specific Avenue of
research as well of course as any
questions or really any comments about
any part of this
so thanks
thank you so much Laura super super
interesting work
um so if folks have any questions please
put those in the Q a and I will moderate
them uh we already have a few questions
there now so first question is how do we
know that these results are not due to
random variability in a sample in other
words where statistical tests used to
determine if these results are actually
significant so you can can you talk a
little bit about those confidence
intervals on your graphs yeah definitely
so all the confidence intervals I guess
I should share my screen again instead
of having stuff up shared it
um
yeah so all of the confidence intervals
shown on our graphs here these are 95
confidence intervals
so we use standard confidence intervals
to test that actually these are
statistically significant gaps and based
on we have a pretty large sample size so
we can be pretty sure that these are
statistically significant and we're
actually picking up on real differences
um instead of random variability and
again having sort of this large
fairly spread out sample across the
ideological Spectrum really helps us
here
thanks another question from David
caslow what beliefs are connected with
anti-Semitism specifically is the belief
in Zero Sum that there is only a fixed
amount of Happiness success money and
then an increase in this amount and one
group decreases this amount in another
group is this idea of zero sum of belief
connected with the anti-Semitism and
something you studied in you know this
paper or other work you have ongoing
yeah so that comes up that's definitely
a proposed theory that comes up
specifically in a lot of the theories
about racial minorities sort of one of
the new theories there is that there's
sort of zero-sum either material
resources or even zero-sum sympathy that
Society Awards to different minority
groups who have suffered and so some of
the anti-Semitic
sentiment we could be picking up on
might be because Jews are perceived as
both
sort of the victims of anti-Semitism but
again they're well off in America
socioeconomically so this does create
sort of this odd
you know tension of well they're being
discriminated against but they're doing
better than other minority so that's
something I'm really interested in
looking at with my next project about
views of privilege and status and how
that affects perceptions of
anti-Semitism does that lead people to
be less sympathetic towards Jews or to
express more anti-semitic sentiments in
general
question from Iran Rubenstein so
um have you looked at any sort of
geographical differences specifically
like Urban versus non-urban pattern in
these results and I'll add on top of
that is uh have you looked at especially
among the young people college educated
versus not college educated yep so we
look at both of these things so I didn't
include any of our regression tables
here because I think it's generally very
overwhelming when someone puts up a
gigantic regression table in a slide but
all of these results here that I'm
showing on graphs we do regression
analysis as well and we find the same
results for all of them but in those
cases we're able to control for college
education and geography in particular so
we look at both of those things
and specifically in our paper about
racial minority anti-semitism
those are two common confounder theories
that are proposed for why racial groups
might have higher rates of anti-Semitism
and we basically dismiss both of those
so yes we have information about college
which we've used to confirm for
geography we only have state level data
unfortunately from yougov so we can't do
anything as direct as you know Ryan Enos
does in his work when he can directly
sort of look at how neighborhoods and
contact
increases prejudice but
there are actually a lot of states where
there are essentially no Jews so we do
compare people who respond from those
States
assuming they have essentially no
contact with Jews with people responding
from states that have a much higher
Jewish population like New York
California Florida and
we don't see
all these things still persist all of
our results still persist and are robust
to that
in a related question from Michelle
Edgar so
some states require Holocaust Education
as as part of like the K-12 schooling
other states do not
have you looked at whether there are any
differences between states that have
that Holocaust Education requirement in
states that don't yeah we haven't looked
at that but that's actually a great idea
and something that I'm curious about and
might fit into maybe the project about
perceptions of Jews is along those lines
but it's about what when we asked people
questions about Jews presumably a large
portion of our respondents don't know
any Jewish people so what are they
thinking about there's probably some
respondents who are like oh like you
know my friends are Jewish and they're
completely normal people I uh you know I
like them but if you don't know Jews
what are you thinking of when you think
of a Jewish American are you thinking of
some stereotype of you know a Hasidic
Jew living in an insular Community
because that's often how especially
observant Jews are portrayed in in media
and in the news or are you thinking of
you know a random reformed Jew who lives
in your town and lives in your community
so that's something that I think is
really interesting and I would love to
look at more because I'm very interested
in how what people know about Judaism
and how all these things lead to
different views on Jews and different
parts of anti-semitism
and I guess following up on that
question about stereotype so I think
Susan Fisk has done some work on
stereotypes towards Jews and if I
remember correctly she finds that most
Americans hold these stereotypes or Jews
are viewed as as high competence but
maybe low on on warmth of you kind of
coolly
assuming that my recollection is correct
does she look at all across the either
age or ideology and and does she see any
sort of of difference along the patterns
that you're finding here or have you
looked at these types of like Susan fist
stereotypes questions and your own work
yeah I'm not sure off the top of my head
what she finds but that's something that
I have been thinking about a lot here
um I know there's also work on how Asian
Americans are viewed and sort of the
idea of racial triangulation which has
been going back I don't know a decade
two decades
um and the idea that minority groups
aren't just viewed on a certain Spectrum
as we would say from sort of like bad to
good but there's a sense of yeah are
they viewed coolly or warmly or in
another sense are they viewed sort of as
Americans were they viewed as permanent
Outsiders and then also are they viewed
as like competent to incompetent
essentially and so I think there
definitely is this push within a lot of
the Prejudice literature to think of
things not just on a single spectrum and
that's something I would definitely want
to expand this work out too because I
think it's
an obvious place to go from here
so we have a few questions from folks on
the what I'll call the why question why
is it that
um the young left uniquely dislikes
Israel
um have you
thought about this have you started to
investigate it what is the role of
social media or media more broadly and
opinion leadership and a different crop
of elected officials coming from the
left and their views towards Israel just
yeah what have you what have you thought
about when it comes to this question of
why have you started to answer this
question if not like how how do you
think you would go about answering this
yeah great question I have definitely
thought a lot about why this is
the question of the media I think okay
so we can say one example is one or
potential reason is that the far left is
actually just anti-semitic and they are
channeling all of those views into a
more socially acceptable
sort of output which would be criticism
of Israel that is sort of one extreme
that may or may not be the case but
there's lots of other potential ideas
that we need to check first the biggest
one is probably this question of media
and exposure so it might be
that people on the far left really just
see lots more news about Israel they see
a lot more news about Israel and
Palestine either because news media
covers it more than than conflicts in
other countries which is probably true
or that people on social media of these
opinion leaders as you talk about are
posting more about Israel and Palestine
we see especially the squad you know AOC
Rasheeda claib ilhan Omar Ayanna Presley
they talk about Israel and Palestine
quite a bit
so it could be that the far left holds
these uniquely negative views on Israel
just because they know more and they are
exposed to more
view to more negative criticism of
Israel and also just exposed in general
to what's going on there because there's
so much going on in the world and we
know people can't really hold real
opinions about what's going on in every
single country as once at once so
I would say those are sort of the two
extremes as to what could be going on
with the far left and it could be
anywhere along that Spectrum
I haven't yet started digging into why
that is because
in part because it's a thorny issue it's
hard to really get at the core of why do
people feel this way about Israel
because again with social desirability
bias coming in if you ask someone who
really is anti-Semitic who holds
negative views of Israel you know why do
you feel this way they're probably going
to come up with a reasonable
justification that's not
I hate Jews so it's a tricky thing to
get at but I think actually going back
to what we were just talking about
exploring what people actually know
about Israel and what they know about
the conflict and things like this could
be one way to go about it and I've
considered something
um
we talked a lot or I talked earlier
about a lot of the parallels that are
drawn between sort of black lives matter
and the israel-palestine conflict and
something I'm broadly interested in is
whether especially people on the far
left not only see those as parallels but
sort of impute U.S race relations on to
Israel and Palestine so do they view
Israelis as they view Jews in America
who are primarily white and do they view
Palestinians as you know they're
primarily Arabs so okay Muslims in the
United States are viewed as not white so
I will view them as not white and that's
sort of a simple issue for the far left
to have a stance on because here in the
United States white people they would
view as the oppressors so they can do
the same as Israel and Palestine
now we also know that I believe still
the majority of Jews in Israel are not
Ashkenazi they're not white they're not
coming from Europe or even America
so I'm interested one thing I had a
thought about is if you prime people
with information about
what like racial demographics in Israel
about Israelis and Palestinians does
that change
any views they have on Israel and I
haven't really thought it through
further than that but that's something I
would be really interested to work on
and someone to do if not me
you should do it it's a great Next Step
um
and a few questions sort of from the the
other side the far right so uh one
question is about just why you think
this is there's an age gap on the far
right between younger and older and a
related question is about religiosity
how much of this do you think is driven
by
um religiously based anti-semitic
attitudes that might hold both among
right-wing white Christians but also
among the Black and Latino population is
more gorgeous so religiosity is an
easier answer which is we actually
control for this both in the ideology
paper and specifically in the minority
anti-Semitism paper and we do find often
higher rates of anti-Semitism among more
religious people but these patterns do
persist even just looking at you know
more religious people still people on
the far right identify or agree more
with these anti-semitic statements and
the same for breaking down racial
minority groups so
religiosity certainly plays a role in
people's views on Jews and anti-Semitism
but it doesn't explain any of these
patterns specifically
going back to why I think Young far
right might be more likely to agree
there's a few things one is
well maybe it's sort of the same thing
so people on The Young I talked about
the growth of the alt-right movement
online
part of sort of the ethos of the
alt-right movement and people on The
Young far right in general is this sort
of reactionary attitude to a lot of you
know so-called political correctness
things like that that are going on and
we see people on The Young far right
being more willing to just Express
hateful views broadly you know we can
think about how social media trolling
might have played a role in that so it
might be that people on The Young far
right
it could be that there's actually a
decreased social desirability bias among
young far-right adults it could be that
you know they're being reactionary they
think it's good to share these honest
attitudes they're like I'm not afraid to
say what I actually think about Jews and
perhaps other minority groups but it
also could be that
because lots of these white nationalist
alt-right movements are growing online
they're particularly attracting young
adults who are overwhelmingly more
online who are going to find these
communities they're going to be on 4chan
things like that and it could be that
just this increased exposure to all of
this
is making them Express more anti-semitic
attitudes in general
and one question from David Nelson is
is there a way to separate out these
attitudes from what's called genuine
attitudes versus
peer-based attitudes where in some
groups and stuff say it's the the cool
thing or the in-group thing to to hold
these anti-semitic attitudes even if the
individual expression of them does not
truly Harbor these these anti-semitic
attitudes yeah do you have any thoughts
on on that and I guess related question
would be either is there a relationship
between these attitudes and any type of
anti-Semitic Behavior
yeah both of those are great questions
we don't have any way of linking that to
anti-semitic behavior and I'm not sure
if
anyone who's ever asked those questions
but that would be a really interesting
thing to look at as well
um I think it's a great question and I
think partially what it's getting at is
this idea of expressive responding on
surveys which is sort of a broad uh a
problem a concern that comes up more
broadly in political science which is
what if people aren't when they take a
survey what if they're not responding
with their genuine view but they're
responding with the view they know they
should hold based on some identity and
we're often really concerned about this
when it comes to partisanship and
thinking about polarization so we see
very polarized views among the left and
the right on all sorts of policy issues
and one question is well
if you ask people their views on
affirmative action for example are
people who are saying well I'm a
Democrat so I'm supposed to support this
so I'll say yes are they saying that
when they fill out a survey or they
actually you know truly in support of
affirmative action it's very hard to
disentangle these things and that could
be part of what's going on here
I would say
it's
partially it's less
I would lean my gut instinct is that
that's less of a concern with our
questions specifically than with a lot
of these more policy-based questions
because it's not exactly clear
that there should be a strict party
divide on these issues you know we might
think oh like white nationalists they're
gonna dislike Jews less but the
Republican party is also very supportive
of Israel and of course that doesn't
mean that they're not anti-semitic these
two views are sort of separate but
a lot of people on the far right would
probably say like oh yeah I am
supportive of Jews you know I support
Israel I support all these things so
it's not clear exactly that there would
be such strong strong expressive
responding but it is something worth
exploring and looking at more definitely
perhaps one way you could get it this is
about people's perceptions of group
Norms you could ask them like what
percent of your friends do you think
would agree with this statement about
double standards
um to see if there's a gap between those
group Norm Perceptions in people's
positions yeah that's a great idea
thanks do that
so we are almost at the top of the hour
um
I believe this talk has been recorded
and
um will be shared in a Cell
um somewhere uh if you want to chime in
it yeah
yes it will be posted on the ipsa
website it's ypsa.yale.edu
in a couple of weeks
great thanks and Laura if folks are
interested in reading these additional
papers is there a place where they can
go to access those
um
probably
um I would guess they're probably on my
co-author Eton Hirsch's website so you
could go there but also anyone is free
to contact me reach out on Twitter you
can find my email and email me and I'd
be happy to share this more with anyone
who's interested
so folks are interested in in the other
papers that we got a brief intro to
um but lots of lots of discussion about
please reach out to to Laura on those
um
So yeah thank you all so much and I hope
everyone has a great Friday afternoon
and a lovely weekend
thanks everyone